don't you think it would be weird for
Eddie to have to go back to stand up now
because you know how hard you work at it
you got to kind of keep that muscle
thriving if you're gonna really be good
at it
everyone is expecting so much from Eddie
the pressure must be crippling how is he
gonna go create new material for
stand-up all eyeballs he will be under a
microscope I mean who's not gonna watch
that everyone is going to everyone who's
gonna watch it and pressure and if you
look at his old specials a lot of that
stuff I don't think could air today on
Netflix that's gonna be the real it
would break my heart if people went
through his old specials that are just
jabs and tore him apart based on today's
standards and what is appropriate and
you know that's a really good discussion
Eddie Murphy I had seen him at The
Comedy Store I want to say like four
years ago walk down the hallway no
kidding and he was kind of he didn't go
on right but it was wild you've been at
the Comedy Store in LA that hallway it's
like Beirut it's loud and people are
yelling and did it uh and he just and
everyone got dad quiet and he just he
levitated down the hall it was like he
was not a people mover
he just levitated down the hallway and
as he kept walking I was like 10 feet
away from me and I just went I said I
love you we all love them I just
panicked